you mentioned the hot water of the pool
that we're both tipping a a toe in uh do
you think Wikipedia has a left-leaning
political bias which is something it is
sometimes accused of yeah so I don't
think so not broadly
um
and you know I think you can always
point to specific entries and talk about
specific biases but that that's part of
the process of Wikipedia anyone can come
and Challenge and and to to go on about
that but you know I I see fairly often
on Twitter you know some uh you know
sort of quite extreme accusations of
bias and I think you know actually I
just I don't see it I don't buy that and
if you ask people for an example they
normally struggle
um and depending on who they are and
what it's about
um so it's certainly true that some
people who have quite Fringe viewpoints
um and who knows the full
Rush of history in 500 years they might
be considered to be path-breaking
Geniuses but at the moment quite Fringe
views and they're just unhappy that
Wikipedia doesn't report on their Fringe
views as being mainstream and that by
the way goes across all kinds of fields
I mean I was once accosted on the street
um
outside the Ted conference in Vancouver
by a guy who's a homeopath who was very
upset that Wikipedia's entry on
Homeopathy basically says it's
pseudoscience
um and he felt that was biased and I
said well I can't really help you
because you know it cites we cite good
quality sources to talk about the
scientific status and it's not very good
so you know it depends and uh you know I
think it's something that we should
always be vigilant about
um but it's uh you know in general I
think we're pretty good and I think any
time you go to any serious
uh political controversy
we should have a pretty balanced
perspective on who's saying what what
the views are and so forth I would
actually argue that the
the areas where we are more likely to
have bias that persist for a long period
of time are actually
fairly obscure things or maybe fairly
non-political things so I just give it's
kind of a humorous example but it's it's
meaningful
uh if you read our entries about uh
Japanese anime uh they tend to be very
very positive and very favorable because
almost no one knows about Japanese anime
except for fans and so the people who
come and spend their days writing
Japanese anime articles they love it
they kind of have an inherent love for
the whole area now they'll of course
being human beings to have their
internal debates and disputes about
what's better or not you know but in
general they're quite positive because
nobody actually cares on anything that
people
quite passionate about then hopefully
you know there's like quite a lot of
interesting stuff so I'll give an
example a contemporary example where I
think we've done a good job as of my
most recent sort of look at it and that
is the the question about the efficacy
of masks during the covet pandemic and
that's an area where I would say the
public authorities really kind of jerked
us all around a bit you know in the very
first days they said whatever you do
don't rush out and buy masks
um and their concern was
uh the shortages in hospitals okay but
fair enough
later it's like no everybody's got to
wear a mask everywhere it's it really
works really well and it's you know then
now I think it's the evidence is mixed
right Mass seem to help in my personal
view Mass seemed to help they're no huge
burden you know you might as well not
wear a mask in any environment where
you're with a giant crowd of people and
so forth
um but it's very politicized that one
and it's very politicized where uh
certainly in the U.S you know much more
so I mean I live in in the UK I live in
London I've never seen kind of on the
streets sort of
the kind of thing that I there's a lot
of reports of people actively angry
because someone else is wearing a mask
um that sort of thing in public
um
and so because it became very
politicized then clearly if Wikipedia if
you go to Wikipedia and you research
this topic I think you'll find more or
less what I've just said I'm like
actually after it's all you know to this
point in history it's mixed evidence
like Mass seemed to help but maybe not
as much as some of the authorities said
and and here we are
and that's kind of an example where I
think okay we've done a good job but I
suspect there are people on both sides
of that very emotional debate who think
this is ridiculous hopefully we've got
quality sources so then hopefully those
people who read this can say oh actually
you know it is complicated you know if
you can get to the point of saying okay
this is I have my view but I understand
other views and I do think it's a
complicated question great now we're a
little bit more mature as a society well
that one is an interesting one because I
feel like I hope that that article also
contains the meta conversation about the
politicization of that topic yeah to me
it's almost more interesting than what
the masks work or not as at least at
this point is like why it became masks
became a symbol of the oppression of a
centralized government if you wear them
you're a sheep that follows the mass
control the mass hysteria of an
authoritarian regime and if you don't
wear a mask then you're a science denier
anti-vaxxer a um alt-right probably a
Nazi
so exactly and that that whole
politicization of society is it's just
so damaging
um and I don't I don't know in broader
in the broader world like how do we
start to fix that that's a really hard
question well at every moment because
you mentioned mainstream and Fringe
there seems to be attention here and I
wonder what your philosophy is on it
because there's mainstream ideas and
there's Fringe ideas uh you look at lab
leak Theory uh for this virus that could
be other things we can discuss
where there's a mainstream narrative
well if you just look at the percent
of the population
or the population with platforms what
they say and then uh what is a small
percentage uh in opposition to that and
what does Wikipedia's responsibility to
accurately represent both the mainstream
and the French do you think well I mean
I I think we we have to try to do our
best to to recognize both but also to
appropriately contextualize and so this
can be quite hard particularly when
emotions are high that's just a fact
about human beings
um I'll give a simpler example because
there's not a lot of emotion around it
like our entry on the moon doesn't say
some say the moon's made of rocks some
say cheese you know who knows that kind
of false neutrality is not what we want
to get to like that doesn't make any
sense but that one's easy like we all
understand
um I think there is a Wikipedia entry
called something like the moon is made
of cheese where it talks about this is a
common sort of joke or or thing that
children say or that people tell to
children or whatever you know it's just
a thing it's everybody's heard Moon's
made of cheese
um but nobody thinks wow like Wikipedia
is so one-sided it doesn't even
acknowledge the cheese Theory
um I say the same thing about Flat Earth
you know again it's exactly what I'm
looking up right now very little
controversy uh we will have an entry
about Flat Earth theory theorizing Flat
Earth people
um my personal view is most the people
who claim to be flat earthers are just
having a laugh trolling and more power
to them have some fun but uh let's not
be you know ridiculous
but of course for mostly human history
people believe that the Earth is flat so
the article I'm looking at is actually
kind of focusing on this history Flat
Earth is an archaic and scientifically
disproven conception of the Earth's
shape as a plane or disc many ancient
cultures subscribe to a flat Earth
cosmography with pretty cool pictures of
what a flat Earth would look like
with dragon is that Dragon No Angels on
the on the edge
there's a lot of controversy about that
what is in the edge is it the wall is it
Angels dragons is there a dome and how
can you fly from
uh South Africa to Perth because on a
flat Earth
view that's really too far for any plane
to make it what I want to know it's all
spread out what I want to know is what's
on the other side Jimmy what's on the
other side that's what all of us want to
know yeah
um
so there's some I presume there's
probably a small section about the
conspiracy theory of Flat Earth because
I think there's a sizeable percent of
the population who at least will say
they believe in a flat Earth yeah I I
think it is a movement
um that just says that the mainstream
narrative
to have distrust and skepticism about
the mainstream narrative which to a very
small degree is probably a very
productive thing to do it's part of the
scientific process but you can get a
little silly and ridiculous with it yeah
I mean yeah it it it's exactly right and
so
um you know I I think I find on on many
many cases and of course I like anybody
else might quibble about this or that in
any Wikipedia article but in general I
think there is a pretty good
um sort of willingness and indeed
eagerness to say oh let's let's fairly
represent all of the meaningfully
important sides so there's still a lot
to unpack in that right so meaningfully
important so you know uh people who
um
are raising questions about the efficacy
of masks okay that's actually a
reasonable thing to have a discussion
about and hopefully we should treat that
as a as a fair conversation to have and
actually address which authorities have
said what and so on and so forth
um and then you know there are other
cases where it's not meaningful
opposition you know like you just
wouldn't say if I I mean I
I doubt if the main article Moon
it may mention
cheese probably not even because it's
not credible and it's not even meant to
be serious by anyone or the article on
the Earth
certainly won't have a paragraph that
says well most scientists think it's
round but
certain people think flat like that's
just a silly thing to put in that
article you would want to sort of
address you know that's an interesting
cultural phenomenon you want to put it
somewhere
um so this you know this goes into uh
all kinds of uh things about politics
um you want to be really careful really
thoughtful about uh not getting caught
up in the anger of our times and really
recognize yes I I always thought
I remember being really kind of proud of
the us at the time when it was uh McCain
was running against Obama because I
thought I've got plenty of disagreements
with both of them but they both seem
like thoughtful and interesting people
who I would have different disagreements
with but I always felt like yeah like
that that's good now we can have a
debate now we can have an interesting
debate and it isn't just sort of people
slamming each other personal attacks and
so forth
and you're saying Wikipedia has also
represented that I hope so yeah and I
think so in in the main obviously you
can always find uh debate that went
horribly wrong because there's humans
involved but speaking of those humans
I would venture to guess I don't know
the data maybe you can
um let me know but the personal
political leaning of the group of people
who out of Wikipedia probably leans left
I would guess
so to me the question there is I mean
the same is true for Silicon Valley the
task for Silicon Valley is to create
platforms that are not politically
biased right even though there is a bias
for the engineers who create it and I
think I believe it's possible to do that
I you know there's kind of conspiracy
theories that it somehow is impossible
and there's this whole conspiracy where
the left is controlling the song I think
I think Engineers for the most part when
to create platforms that are open and
unbiased that are that create all kinds
of perspective because that's super
exciting to have all kinds of
perspectives battle it out but yeah
still is there is there a degree to
which the personal political bias of the
editors might seep in in Silly Ways in a
big ways Silly Ways could be uh I think
hopefully I'm correct in saying this but
the right will call
it's the Democrat Party
and the left will call it the Democratic
party right yeah like subtle it always
hits my ear weird like are we children
here we're like we're literally taking
words and like just jabbing at each
other like yeah I could I could like
capitalize a thing in a certain way or I
can like just just take a war to mess
with them that's a small way of how you
use words but you can also you know have
a a bigger way about uh about beliefs
about various perspectives on political
events and uh Hunter Biden's laptop on
how big of a story that is or not I've
been in censorship of that story is or
not that kind of and then there's these
camps that take very strong points and
they construct big narratives around
that and they I mean it's very sizable
percent of the population believes the
two narratives that compete with each
other yeah I mean it's
it's really interesting
um and it feels but I it's hard to judge
you know the The Sweep of History within
your own lifetime yeah but it feels like
it's gotten much worse uh that this idea
of two parallel universes
um where people kind of agree on certain
basic facts uh feels uh worse than it
used to be and I'm not sure if that's
true or if it just feels that way but I
also I'm not sure what the causes are I
think I I would lay a lot of the blame
um in in recent years
on
social media algorithms
which reward clickbait headlines which
reward
tweets that go viral and they go viral
because they're cute and clever I mean
my most successful tweet ever by a
fairly wide margin
some reporter tweeted it Elon Musk
because he was complaining about
Wikipedia or something you should buy
Wikipedia and I just wrote not for sale
and you know 90 zillion retweets and
people liked it and it was all very good
but I'm like you know what it's cute
line right and it's a good like mic drop
and all that and I was pleased with
myself like it's not really discourse
right it's not really sort of the what I
like to do but it's what social media
really rewards which is kind of uh lets
you and him have a fight right and
that's more interesting I mean it's
funny because at the time I was I was
texting with Elon who very pleasant to
me and all of that he might have been a
little bit shitty the reporter might
have been a little bit shitty but you
fed into the shitty snarky funny of a
response not for sale and like where do
you like what so that's a funny little
exchange and you could probably after
that laugh it off and yeah fun well like
that kind of mechanism that rewards the
snark yeah can go into viciousness yeah
yeah well and we certainly see it
um online you know I like a a a series
of tweets you know sort of a a a tweet
thread of 15 tweets that assesses the
quality of the evidence for masks pros
and cons and and sort of where this
that's not going to go viral you know
um but you know a Smackdown for
a famous politician who is famously in
favor of masks who also went to a dinner
and didn't wear a mask that's going to
go viral and you know that that's partly
human nature
um you know people love to call out
hypocrisy and all that but it's partly
what these systems Elevate automatically
I talk about this with respect to
Facebook for example so I think Facebook
has done a pretty good job
although it's taken longer than it
should in some cases but you know if you
have a
a very large following and you're really
spouting hatred or or misinformation
disinformation they've kicked people off
they've done you know some reasonable
things there but actually the deeper
issue is
um of this this um the anger we're
talking about of the the contentiousness
of everything
I make of a family example
um with two great stereotypes um so one
the the the crackpot Racist uncle and
one the sweet grandma
and I always want to point out my all of
my uncles and my family were wonderful
people so I didn't have a crackpot racer
but everybody knows the stereotype yeah
well so Grandma she just posts like
sweet comments on the kids pictures and
congratulates people on their wedding
anniversary and crackpot uncles posting
his nonsense
and normally it's sort of at Christmas
dinner everybody rolls their eyes oh
yeah uncle Frank's here and he's
probably gonna say some racist comment
and we're gonna tell him to shut up or
you know maybe let's not invite him this
year the normal human drama
he's got his three mates down at the pub
who listen to him and and all of that
but now
Grandma's got you know 54 followers on
Facebook which is the intimate family
and Racist uncle has 714. so he's not a
massive influence or whatever but how
did that happen it's because the
algorithm notices oh when when she posts
nothing happens he posts and then
everybody jumps in to go gosh shut up on
Uncle Frank you know like that's
outrageous
and it's like oh there's engagement
there's page views there's ads right and
and those algorithms I think they're
working to improve that but it's really
hard for them it's hard to improve that
if that actually is working if the
people who are saying things that get
engagement
um if it's not too awful but it's just
you know like maybe it's not a racist
Uncle but maybe it's an uncle who posts
a lot about what an idiot Biden is Right
which isn't necessarily an offensive or
blockable or bannable thing and it
shouldn't be
but if that's the discourse that gets
elevated because it gets a rise out of
people then suddenly in a society it's
like oh this is we get more of what we
reward so I I think that's a piece of
what's gone on